let's do some more volumes of solids of
revolutions so let's say that I have the
graph y is equal to square root of x so
let's do it so it looks something like
this so that right over there is y is
equal to the square root of x and let's
say I also have the graph of y equals x
so let's say y equals x looks something
like this it looks just like that
y equals x and what I care about now is
the the solid I get if I were to rotate
if I were to rotate the area between
these two things around the x axis so
let's try to visualize it so the outside
is going to be kind of a a truffle shape
it's going to look like a truffle shape
and then we hollow out a cone inside of
it so let me my best attempt to draw
this shape so it's going to look
something like it's going to look
something like okay so the outside is
going to look something like this
it's going to look something like that
and we care about the interval we care
about the interval between the points
that they intersect so between this
point and this point here so the outside
is going to look something like this so
this is the base of the truffle that is
the base of the truffle it's going to
have this kind of truffle shape on the
outside but I guess maybe we're on some
type of a diet we don't want to eat the
entire truffle so we carve out a cone on
the inside so the inside of it is
essentially hollow except for this kind
of shell part so we carve we carve out
we carve out a cone we carve out a cone
in the center so we rotate it around the
x-axis truffle on the outside carved out
a cone on the inside so what's going to
be the volume of that thing so it's
essentially it's essentially if we take
a slice of our figure it's going to be
this is going to be the wall and we're
essentially going to take the volume of
this entire wall that we're rotating
that we're rotating around the X
axis so how do we do that well it might
dawn on you that if we found the volume
of the truffle if it was not carved out
and then subtract from that the volume
of the cone we would essentially find
out the volume of the space in between
the the outside of the truffle and the
the cone part of the truffle so how
would we do that
well so to find the volume of the outer
shape so let me draw it over here so
actually let me draw it over here the if
we think about the volume of the outer
shape once again we can use the disk
method so at any given point in time our
radius for one of our disks is going to
be equal to the function let's rotate
that disk around actually let me do it
in a different color it's hard to see
that disks in the same magenta so this
is a radius and let's rotate it around
so I'm rotating the disk around this is
our face of the disk that's our face of
the disk it's going to have a depth of
DX we've seen this multiple times it's
going to have a depth of DX so the
volume of this disk is going to be our
depth DX times the area of the face the
area of the face is going to be pi times
the radius squared the radius is going
to be equal to the value of the outer
function in this case it's square root
of x so it's going to be pi times our
radius squared which is pi times square
root of x squared and so if we want to
find the volume of the entire outer
thimble or truffle or whatever we want
to call it before we were before we even
carve out the center we just take a sum
of a bunch of these a bunch of these
disks that we've created so that's one
disk we would have another disk over
here another disk over here for each X
we have another disk and as we go as X's
get larger and larger the disks have a
larger and larger radius so we're going
to sum up all of those disks all of
those disks and we take the limit as
each of those disks gets infinitely thin
and we have an infinite number of them
but we have to figure out our boundaries
of integration so what are our
boundaries of integration what are the
two points right over here where they
intersect well we could just set these
two things to
equal to each other if you just said X
is equal to square root of x when does X
equal square root of x I mean you could
square both sides of this you could say
when does x squared equal X you could
well we could we could keep it there you
could kind of solve this there's
multiple ways you could do it but you
could solve this kind of just thinking
about it if X is equal to 0 x squared is
equal to X and you see that on the graph
right over here X is equal to 0 and also
1 squared is equal to 1 1 is equal to
the square root of 1 you could have done
other things you could say ok x squared
minus X is equal to 0 you could factor
out an X you get x times X minus 1 is
equal to 0 and so either one of these
could be equal to 0 so X is equal to 0
or X minus 1 is equal to 0 and then you
get x equals 0 or X is equal to 1 X is
equal to 0 or x equals 1 which gives us
our boundaries of integration so this
goes from x equals 0 to x equals 1 and
so for the outside of our shape we can
now figure out the volume but we're not
done we also need to figure out the
volume of the inside of our shape that
we're going to take out so we're going
to subtract out that volume so we're
going to subtract out a volume our X
values once again are going between 0 &
1 and so let's think about those disks
so let's think about it let's construct
the disk on the inside right over here
so if I construct a disk on the inside
so now I'm carving out the cone part of
it what is what is the area of the face
of one of those disks well it's going to
be pi times the radius squared in this
case the radius is going to be equal to
the value of this inner function which
is just X so pi times and so this is
just Y is equal to X and then we're
going to multiply it times the depth
times the depth of each of these disks
and each of these disks are going to
have a depth of DX if you imagine 1/4
that has a infinitely thin and
infinitely thin depth right over here so
it's going to be DX and so the volume of
our kind of our
our truffle with the cone carved out is
going to be this integral minus this
integral right over here and we could
evaluate it just like that or we could
even say okay we could factor out a pie
out of both of them it actually there's
multiple ways that we could write it but
let's just evaluate it like this and
then I'll generalize it in the next
video
so this is going to be equal to the
definite integral from 0 to 1 you take
the pie outside the square root of x
squared is going to be X DX minus the
integral we can factor the pie out from
0 to 1 of x squared x squared DX and we
could say this is going to be equal to
actually let me just do this is equal to
pi times the antiderivative of X which
is just x squared over 2 evaluated from
0 to 1 minus pi times the antiderivative
of x squared which is X to the third
over 3 evaluated from 0 to 1 this
expression is equal to and I'm going to
arbitrarily switch colors just because
the greens getting monotonous
pi times 1 squared over 2 minus 0
squared over 2 I could write it squared
1 squared over 2 minus 0 squared over 2
minus pi times 1 to the 3rd over 3 minus
0 to the third over 3 and so we get this
is equal to this is equal to let me do
that same blue color it's equal to so
this is just simplify this is just 0
right over here this is 1 squared over 2
which is just 1/2 so it's just PI over 2
1/2 times pi minus well this is just
this is just 0 this is 1/3 minus PI over
3 minus PI over 3 and then to simplify
this it's just really subtracting
fractions so we can find a common
denominator common denominator is 6 this
is going to be 3 PI over 6 this is 3 PI
over 6 minus 2 PI over 6 minus 2 PI over
6 PI over 3 is 2 PI over 6
over two is three PI over six and we end
up with we end up with three of
something - two of something you end up
with one of something we end up with one
PI over six and we are done we were able
to find the volume of that wacky kind of
gutted out truffle